it is so amazing being here in times
square and it's so amazing just being
minutes away from 2022 we feel so much
energy around us everyone is so excited
to ring in the new year to ring in 2022
and all that it holds lawrence what are
you most excited about for 2022
i'm looking for the future but i'm
looking forward to getting back to some
normals as well when we went down there
it was a smaller crowd but we got here
it seems like people are making their
way in because they're excited for
what's about to come they're so excited
you can feel the energy you can feel the
anticipation we are minutes away from
2022 right here in the heart of new york
city lawrence it's such an honor to be
here with you to all of you guys in
nashville and all of you guys watching
at home right here in the epicenter of
new york city it's incredible that's
right
we're going to send it back to you guys
in nashville and then we'll see you guys
when the ball drops
yeah we're a minute and 45 seconds for
the ball dropping in new york city we're
told in moments
mayor bill de blasio's term will expire
and he will hit the button and we will
all say thank
thank
you
it's over
[Music]
that's why they're there
thank you
[Music]
that's how a lot of people feel so he's
gonna take so at some point bill de
blasio will take the stage and we will
give him a minute of tv the last
hopefully we give him on the fox news
channel for a very long time
as he presses the button he's definitely
the most hated man in new york city it's
very interesting that this is going to
be oh there we go
he's got a mask
[Applause]
[Music]
oh people are removing their masks so
that they can kiss dr fauci will not
like that
at all no kissing a countdown here
as the ball is set to drop in new york
city
that mask is below your nose be careful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these little towns
[Music]
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
i want to wake up
in a city
that never sleeps
[Music]
king of the hills
these little towns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
gonna make a brand new
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up if you
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else